hello
a bullet train blitz brings us easy
breezy breath so let's like let's have
some fun before before we go out
i have to admit i wasn't expecting an
invitation back from trains to planes
this is your captain speaking top gun
maverick soars into the record books and
puts its stars to the test you're
strapped to a chair you're blindfolded
and then they slowly start submerging
you in water
and flick
plus chris hemsworth bears all you can
hear right here from me
full chris booty in high definition in
like 4k oh you flick too hard damn it
the download starts right now
after a pandemic production pause
blockbusters are back and better than
ever yes we're gonna spend today's
episode revisiting the movies that had
us glued to the big screen this summer
and first we're boarding brad pitt's
bullet train
[Music]
listen my guy look at you
i'm great oh here it goes look
i didn't think i had any more firsts
than me but talking to brad pitt about
fashion is a first you've been giving us
all the looks
what is it what is it in you that's
saying let me have a little fun that's
it man we're just going to die so let's
like let's have some fun before before
we go out
fun-loving brad rocked a lime green
linen suit and jumped for joy in front
of the cameras you could say it became
brad's go-to red carpet move
and brad's fast on his feet as an
assassin in the action thriller which
brought in enough bucks to push brad
closer to the 9 billion mark that's how
much his movies have earned total across
his career
[Music]
and brad's loving the comedy infused
action
[Music]
but how has this been something you've
never done before as long as you've been
acting and doing the damage as long as
you golden i didn't mean it like that
i don't know it just hadn't crossed my
path brad's action comeback started with
this cameo in the lost city getting you
out of here why are you so handsome my
dad was a weatherman
and it began with this classic we're not
supposed to talk about gentlemen
welcome to fight club just spoke to me i
i was just really drawn to the thing and
um i'm almost uh scared to categorize
that
brad volunteered to get his teeth
chipped for the role of tyler durden
then went back to the dentist to fix his
pearly whites do what you like
and five years later he quit smoking for
troy
[Applause]
and he could barely walk after getting
injured on set next brad pitt
achilles hurts achilles you can't do
that headline though i'll tell you it
didn't happen it did it
yeah stupid stupid twist of stupid irony
brad's interview with the vampire
co-star tom cruise also had the need for
speed this summer and his top gun
maverick mission pushed his co-stars to
the limit
just can't create this kind of
experience unless you shoot it live
[Music]
for the long awaited sequel tom put his
cast through their paces in real life
teaching them to fly and survive the
dunker you're strapped to a chair you're
blindfolded and then they slowly start
submerging you in water
you take a final breath and then it
starts to flip you upside down and then
you have to get out do you remember like
the first time you launched off one of
these things
they tell you to keep your arms like
this because like you're gonna go flying
forward i decide that i wanna
i wanna take a video of the whole moment
my phone
goes fly explosion yeah just slingshot
we are cleared into the area
of course the sequel is full of high
flying action and a highly anticipated
reunion between tom and iceman vel
kilmer
there's one particular scene between val
and and tom that just man
right in the fields talking to tom about
that moment
it really was like they started their
careers out together they've had this
wild amazing journey
i am dangerous
you know in the first one i really
rallied hard for him to make the movie
that was like you val you got to make
this movie you know this was like this
is going to be it would be amazing
[Music]
e.t was on set with val when he filmed
the og move my father was in the air
force i was excited to be able to get to
see an aspect of the navy that civilians
can't see
do these hollywood types really have the
right stuff to be top gun
they're trainable barely
while the role of maverick was written
for tom he turned it down multiple times
who didn't grow up wanting to fly an
f-14 so it's very easy falling into the
role
and get this glenn powell says he almost
didn't take the role of hangman in the
sequel because he wanted miles teller's
part but tom talked him into it which
one he all has what it takes to follow
me you know this is a lesson for all of
us don't say no to tom cruise so the
beach football montage is it true that
you guys shot it twice because tom was
like i didn't like the way that was the
first time we don't know why we shot it
the second time no no we know we shot in
a second
top gun maverick recently soared past
the 1.4 billion dollar mark at the
global box office easily making it
paramount's highest grossing film ever
with tom cruise expected to earn at
least 100 million dollars from the
blockbuster it's daunting and there's
not one person in this movie that wasn't
sweating bullets and i said you know
what if you're not sweating bullets
making this film you shouldn't be on
this movie
a lot of sweat also went into making the
newest thor flick yeah but have we seen
the last of the god of thunder
now is it safe to assume that this will
be your final go-around as thor look i'm
open to anything you know director taika
waititi has some ideas okay thor and a
buddy on a road trip to vegas christmas
christmas christmas
thor a christmas two christmas chris
pratt
and thor guys take this down star lord
thor
road trip movie
christmas
the first time chris wielded the hammer
was 11 years ago fast forward to love
and thunder and this marks his ninth mcu
movie
well you're right
natalie portman returned to the
franchise as jane foster wielding her
own hammer jane
that girl looks ripped were you two gym
buddies we were a bit yeah yeah she she
worked hard i just want to say that was
very very impressive what you did back
there
[Music]
natalie your arms in this film what was
the training process like for you
it was really exciting to be
cast as a character who's like six foot
when i'm 5'3 it's just my first bad guy
you never forget your first
that bad guy is christian bale who went
through his own transformation to play
gore the god butcher i was already quite
skinny for the film uh that i'd made
before and also how can you compete with
chris in terms of the muscles would have
you know looked pitiful by comparison
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
in the film
is the booty blurred like the trailer
you get full booty in the movie
full crisp booty in high definition go
see it on imax it's even bigger et was
exclusively with the stars in australia
as they destroyed the set
entertainment tonight hey welcome
everybody to new asgard my name is tiger
weissenzi and this
is chris hemsworth
it was a sweet quaint little village
once upon a time but uh if you turn the
camera over here you'll see there's been
quite a fair amount of destruction this
is the biggest set i've ever been on
natalie you want to smash it we know
we've been ruining the set
it feels so good
i missed
again
we love that thor features two of
hollywood's hottest chris's but chris
pratt didn't just battle aliens in love
and thunder he also wrangled raptors
taking a dino-sized bite of the box
office in jurassic world dominion
i heard that the first kiss you guys
ever had in jurassic world was a
surprise
so yes and no it wasn't a surprise to me
it was a surprise to everyone who was
there that day because it wasn't written
here's a little a little thing to know
about me i'm always vying to kiss
you're like chris pratt in these movies
and
and this the dominion was the only time
that there's actually been a kiss
written in me right the need for the
will they won't face sexual chemistry
does not fall on us in this film right
it's laura and sam yeah mm-hmm i'm
telling you
red-hot
that's true yeah it's true red-hot ellie
sadler
alan grant you're reunited with sam how
was that amazing i mean sam neil is the
dream come true as an actor as a friend
to go through hard times with um he's
just an extraordinary gentleman people
were waiting for the romance between you
and sam
it's it's a kiss 30 years in the making
also 30 years in the making laura dern
sam neil and jeff goldblum's jurassic
park reunion
why do they always have to go bigger
one of my favorite memories of the whole
experience was
the first day that sam neil and jeff
goldblum and i had a scene together we
got into a jeep and as we got in
position we looked out and the crew was
surrounding the jeep and teary-eyed
fun fact jeff goldblum has played dr ian
malcolm in the jurassic park franchise
four times jim carrey auditioned for the
role too you made a promise
to a dinosaur yeah
why for most of us we grow older and we
just grow older you've grown older and
you grew cooler to a new generation
what is that like i dreamed of being an
actor when i was a kid
right around ninth grade i would write
please god let me be an actor and i've
gotten a chance to do it and here's a
little behind the scenes secret the cast
had to re-record some of their lines at
home due to the pandemic i will remember
well my daughter across the house
coming in freaked out terrified because
i was screaming bloody murder
because i was running from a
giganotosaurus but in my closet mom
you're going to scare the neighbors i'm
like i'm sorry i'm making a dinosaur
movie in my closet
is this the end of the line for your
character no one could have told me i
was ever going to play dr ellie sattler
again when we made this movie in 93. so
i ain't saying anything that's true
right you never know come back i always
come back
another beloved character who made quite
the comeback buzz lightyear this summer
we got to meet the man behind the toy
and who better to voice him than captain
america himself chris evans
complete the sentence for me to infinity
and beyond oh my gosh what was it like
the first time you said it
uh nerve-wracking really well yeah
because it's something that we all know
from someone else ready captain
lightyear ready as i'll ever be
commander hawthorne it's big shoes to
fill and you want to put your own
interpretation on it but you also have
to make sure you pay homage to what we
all know and what we all love
well not everyone loved that tim allen
the original buzz lightyear in the toy
story films was missing from the latest
pixar flick they didn't let tim allen do
it i don't understand that just as long
as people come back to the motion
picture theater
[Applause]
this was actually pretty intimidating
you know because obviously tim allen is
blessed like yeah and it's tough to try
and fill those shoes i'm using what he
did
as a blueprint he is buzz lightyear will
always be blessed to infinity and beyond
also teaming up with buzz in this space
mission in light year now streaming on
disney plus uzo aduba as his longtime
commander and kiki palmer as a space
ranger in training if we could explore
any other character in the toy story
universe is there any anybody you would
you would like to explore
i would love to see woody's
story i'm curious about the mr potato
head you gotta say
kiki palmer not only brought the
adventure but the screams this summer
co-starring in jordan peel's thriller
nope
yeah no no no one i heard that part of
the reason you got this role is because
you slid into director jordan peele's
dms is that true i did slide it to his
dms however he never read it has he ever
gone back and read it
i don't know to this day if he's ever
read it but i remember him saying
i wrote her only with you in mine so
that was just like the greatest
compliment i could have ever had let's
go baby let's go daniel kaluuya plays
palmer's brother and the two are
determined to find undeniable proof that
aliens exist the film marks the third
team up between daniel and the get out
director daniel and i you know that's
like my my dream collaborator as a
director so yeah that's my brother right
there explain what this movie is about
in one sentence if you could it's about
spectacle and r
that's a comma
and our
oh
yeah
and our obsession with attention yeah
there are lots of theories floating
around about the deeper meaning of
pure's third thriller but one thing's
for sure doa's brandon perea was psyched
to be part of the action i love seeing
you geeking out and checking out your
poster seeing my face massive i just
started crying but this moment being
here is just unbelievable it's a miracle
as someone else who definitely saw his
face on a lot of billboards this summer
austin butler yeah his grueling elvis
audition proved he had the chops to play
the iconic singer but what about the
look well he had some help from a little
movie magic
when you look in the mirror and you
start to see the transformation it makes
you feel different
it really does
turning into elvis was no easy feat
austin dyed his hair black and wore more
than 90 costumes for the film there's so
many things out there that have become
these caricatures and so even talking
about him curling his lip it's something
he didn't do as much as we think he did
right or do it for a photo and so he was
finding how subtle could you go with
things
and still have the essence so what
you're telling me is you already had the
moves
i had to work hard
not only did he have the accent and
dancing down austin also saying all the
elvis songs himself check out this early
screen test
well that's all right mama
that's all right for you
i used to only ever sing for people very
close to you because i i didn't believe
it in the beginning but i wanted to i
wanted to take on the challenge
harry styles was actually a big
contender for the role of elvis but
director baz lerman turned him down
because quote he's harry styles he's
already an icon bass says austin was
born to play the part they hadn't even
started auditioning yet i sent
baja a video of
me playing the piano and singing
unchained melody
the 31 year old actor also had the
support of the king's own family
watching him play your fault it did
something to me it really did and so
what did it do to you oh a lot a lot i
wasn't ready for what it did that's kind
of left me alone in the theater the
first time i saw it after the film i
just fell into him in tears the moment
that i saw austin
on stage i started crying
now to another film that came out of the
gate strong where the crawdad scene the
film based on the best-selling book
raked in 17 million opening weekend not
too shabby since it only cost 24 million
to make which means it's straight to the
bank for reese witherspoon who had a
major hand in bringing it to the big
screen how soon after reading this book
did you know you had to have the rights
we picked it for the book club um
probably in 2018 was like yes and it's
just been a dream come true
[Music]
a dream that's been four years in the
making for reese and her all-female
filmmaking team only e.t can take you
behind the scenes of the louisiana set
it starts with a crime there's a person
who's been murdered there's no
fingerprints on the railing great snap
daisy edgar jones stars as kaya a young
girl who grew up alone in the swamps of
north carolina you really
don't know if she did it right she's
she's been so outcast in society she's
been treated so poorly by people that
it's really possible that she might have
committed this crime
the marsh girl she killed him this film
is so many things it's a love story a
story about survival but it's also a
sort of courtroom drama and there's this
really big thriller aspect to the film
and how about this taylor swift wrote
the song carolina for the film's credits
there's buzz it could lead to her first
oscar knot
[Music]
it was just a call that she made one day
she was so inspired by the book it's
haunting it's beautiful and
it's just the perfect way to end the
whole movie
[Music]
well there's another movie featuring the
vocal stylings of taylor swift dc league
of super pets what do you listen to
message in the bottle
taylor's immersion i'm listening to it
right now i could tell you're really
it's good that's at the end of our movie
super fast kevin hart and dwayne johnson
joined forces once again for the family
film but is this the end of their
bromance this is the fifth time we're
seeing you and kevin hart team up
together
the fifth time and the last time that
we've done it
and another pair is teaming up for the
first time in more than a decade i can't
wait and i'm anticipating just joy
bts the download returns
[Music]
of all the places i could be
i just wanted to share with you
multiverse madness huh from laughs to
tears to edge of our seat action
michelle yo ushered in the summer
blockbuster season with everything
everywhere all at once a24 is highest
grossing film of all time i got to my
agent calling me and saying
there's this weird movie with these
weird directors
um but it stars michelle yo
and i said yes i i didn't need to read
it for me to be able to watch this work
that
no other actress in the world
could pull off
except michelle yo that's why i showed
up
oh my god
now we also heard michelle on something
a little more family-friendly yeah
that's right she joined steve carell for
the latest despicable me flick and this
time we got to dive into the backstory
behind a beloved cartoon super villain
what do you think it is about the
minions that people
also find so lovable they are
equal parts obnoxious and hysterical and
silly
and i think they represent a side of all
of us that we sometimes like to be but
can't always be
i am pretty despicable you don't want to
crush me
michelle joined the minions universe as
healer master chow and taraji p henson
plays a 70s style villain named bell
bottom yeah baby are there any
similarities i love music from the 70s
i was born in 1970 i can rock an afro i
have one
danny trejo plays stronghold
[Applause]
and dolph lundgren remember him from
rocky iv
he plays vengeance
i hear he's a hell of a roller skater
he's a character he's a viking on skates
yeah from the 70s and steve is working
as hard as a minion in another film with
his former office co-star john krasinski
come here you come here you guys spend
so much time together almost a decade
ago and now you're working together
again what's that feeling like i'm
anticipating just joy no more meetings
this week you just agree to that i can
be very surprising it will be a role
reversal from their days on the office
john will be in charge directing steven
paramount's family film if it co-stars
ryan reynolds and is due out next year
in june steve and his minions got
cemented into hollywood history at the
legendary tcl chinese theater i was
worried that he wouldn't be able to get
out of the cement it was so so
ridiculous i couldn't help but laugh
like what am i
what is happening
[Music]
frequent collaborators dwayne johnson
and kevin hart really cemented their
friendship when kevin scored a smooch
from the rock at his 2019 handed
footprint ceremony now besties are
bringing the laughs once again in dc
league of super pets ace deploy k9
shield what is a k-9
so what is it about these animated
projects now you're just like in the
groove with that and is it for the kids
at this point what is it yeah it
definitely has a lot to do with the kids
i think um you had so many well it's
like you know well wait that's not canon
though
right
[Laughter]
in dc league of super pets a group of
rescue pets with super powers go on a
wild mission to help superman and the
justice league but this isn't the rock's
only superhero movie we've got you
coming out as black adam so kev when are
you going to take on a superhero role
man
you know i really thought about it but
then i was like
man
yeah like those roles are
stupid who's upset you went and shot
black adam
secretly told me that you weren't
working and i found out through social
media that you were done production
look at that until white adam comes up
oh white adam's what you got up your
sleeve oh really yeah after all we've
been through
before that happens the rock and kevin
are joined by their hollywood pals john
krasinski vanessa bear jamila jamil and
keanu reeves in the superhero comedy out
now why does it work so well between dj
and kevin they have a nice kind of
free zone
and really good heart this is the fifth
time we're seeing you and kevin hart
team up together this is the fifth time
and the last time that we did no i love
kevin i love kevin and we always have
the best time on screen off screen
listen if kevin and duane are in a movie
i'm going to go see i love your love
love it all right that's gonna do it for
us today guys be sure to join us
tomorrow for a new episode of et's the
download
[Music]